nous parlions au début de ce journal de
la lutte contre l'exclusion et de
l'engagement de certaines personnalités
de la société civile et bien en voici un
autre exemple et il va vous faire
sourire après neuf mois de travail et
l'aide d'un spécialiste guy bedos une
troupe de vaulx en velin dans la
banlieue lyonnaise
présenté hier soir son spectacle un état
de notre société et un regard forcément
caustique cherche mondor et philippe iv
les douze jeunes ont réussi un pari fou
avec l'aide de guy bedos et de didier
vignali un metteur en scène lyonnais
jouer un spectacle jamais lieu je te
fais comme ça ce vieux spectre est fait
par des gens comme ça avec ce temps là
et dans la pub des rasoirs gillette la
pub des rasoirs gillette et ben il ya
toutes les bêtes sauf la mienne c'est
pas fini à croire qu'elle départ mais
chez nous
une performance pour ces jeunes neuf
mois auparavant aucun d'eux n'était
jamais monté sur scène ils sont issus de
vaulx en velin ils ont été recrutées en
avril dernier par les associations
locales pour participer à cette
opération pas ordinaire johan la bande
qui était totalement bloquée qui
arrivait pas à communiquer même dans la
vie qui était complètement dyslexiques
extra et que je le vois où je la voit
gambader sur scène parler c'est jerry
c'est de toute façon sur le plan humain
c'est déjà une victoire
une vingtaine de sketches dont 6,2 bedos
de de sa composent ce spectacle durant
1h30 il aborde avec humour leur problème
d'intégration les médias et leurs
rapports avec la police alors un gain de
plus que murray font ça fait trop
longtemps que vous ne passiez de
montceau librairie le les verts pensent
que vous êtes en virage et que vous
préparez un mauvais de coupe
pendant toute la durée des répétitions
ils ont bénéficié d'un contrat emploi
solidarité
maintenant il devrait rejoindre le club
méditerranée pour un contrat de
qualification de six mois l issue duquel
une embauche est prévue les gens qui
quittent y avait un aspect qui est
plutôt critique sur nos du style c'est
des gens qui arriveront à rien et ben
voilà on leur faire voir que ces
coiffures de mitis une quinzaine de
villes sont déjà intéressés par ce
spectacle qui devrait prochainement
investir une scène parisienne les
banlieues les îles c'est terminé j'en
suis sorti et je compte pertes sitôt
alors si vous voulez me voir la paix